how do you feel though representation
has changed for Asian Americans I feel
like
I feel like it's gotten better but I
feel like there's still work to do well
you know I think it has gotten better in
that it's more there
um
I still think the conversation is too
focused on positive representation of
Asian Americans and I think that's
another trap I don't think we need
positive representation I think we need
whole human representation which
includes our faults which includes
talking about things that are difficult
in the community such as the
internalized misogyny that happens such
as me talking about what happened on the
show
um holding each other accountable out of
love
um
you know because it's to just have a
an Asian love interest with six-pack abs
why can't we have one that doesn't have
six pack abs yeah do you know what I
mean we totally got some under here
I was doing a load but I mean it should
be that you are loved and Worthy as you
are yeah with all your flaws your even
if you don't have a six-pack I think I
mean I'm pretty average I feel like I'm
the most average human ever and I like a
real representation yeah you know what
I'm saying like when you're saying a
whole thing I want the real I want the I
want all of it because I have all of it
but Asian Americans have a history of
being mocked in um especially in popular
culture and I think that is why there
has been this sort of over-correction of
wanting to be cool such as like when I
did fresh off the boat people were very
mad that my character had an accent so
much so that some actors would say I
Asian actors would say I refuse
to play any character that has an Asian
accent and I almost feel like that
refusal
almost you're saying there's something
wrong with it yeah almost
strengthens the Antiquated idea that
there's something inherently shameful or
buffoonish about an accent you look at
it objectively all it means is that you
know two languages that is friggin cool
that's something to be proud of I've
been trying for years yeah so let's make
our choice but but like you let's make
our choices rather than making our
choices a reaction to A system that has
mocked us and doesn't understand us
let's be creative not reactive let's
make our own system and if somebody
doesn't get it if somebody laughs at the
wrong thing somebody's always gonna get
it you don't create art to cater to
ignorant people you create art because
it's out of your soul so we need the six
packs but we also need the kegs yeah
I love you
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
I'm going